[Music]
this is detective Dale DiNardo he works
with some of the toughest customers in a
business real monsters really I'm not
kidding they're monsters gila monsters
these characters have been causing some
problems around the US and Norwich
desert
[Music]
you
and
don't get fit
best of pet food
okay okay monsters have to eat just like
everyone else
right but Dale he wants to keep tabs on
these suspects you know keep him out of
trouble
the problem is these monsters are very
secretive and spend about 95% of their
time underground that makes them tricky
to watch so Dale is gonna use a really
cool spy gadget to track them
electronically
first though he's got a catch one so he
hangs around one of their favorite
hideouts waiting and waiting and waiting
okay that didn't work so well so he's
gonna set a trap and try and nab one
that way
this Gila right here is about to take an
unexpected turn right into detective
fales clutches to insert the tracking
device Dale has to perform some minor
surgery
the monster is put to sleep
you see those teeth right there they may
look small but they're sharp and they're
about 50
there we are perfect fit next their
releases the Gila back to its home bye
bye baby
the transmitter will allow Dale to keep
tabs on this guy for the next three
months the device inside the Gila sends
electronic signals to Dale's equipment
real close clever huh
now perhaps he'll be able to keep those
little monsters out of trouble
[Music]